[Music]
i can't believe you got this cover and i
didn't of muscle fitness
um and then yeah
i'm sorry who rubs their own trash
is that what you do you walk by and you
oh look
i'm that guy yeah yeah
[Music]
and once hilarious he has the real thing
on him there yeah stop moving them okay
looks like there's popcorn popping in
there i mean i'm curious tell us how now
i'm telling you i could start i could
have started weightlifting at some point
and this would never have happened to me
i'd need uh some kind of a male hormone
i suppose no
but you
uh i'm just curious what you said what
age did you start really seriously
lifting i seriously started working out
at 14 years old and again i mean that's
the nfl body i mean that's that's that's
the body that comes from hitting people
at 15 miles an hour you know it just
doesn't happen overnight but this is the
thing i just never stopped when i
retired from the nfl in 97 i just
decided you know what just keep working
out most guys stop if you look at most
guys after the nfl they're like 500
pounds or whatever i'm not i just
decided to keep going and it turned out
the way my career went it it it worked
for everything what's your i'm just
curious what do you do like what in the
morning do you get up and crack like
three eggs into your mouth and then lift
two bank safes how does it work
no i i am the guy who opens up the gym
i'm there at five in the morning i've
spent two hours a day
doing this
i get there at 4 30 and it's not open
yet
see you go for
then i get pancakes
then i get a croissant
then i go to american girl store
and i come back to the gym and there's
no room that's my problem so so you open
the gym you're there you're working out
i mean would you be able to transform
someone like me be honest you're serious
you know that right no that's not that's
broken
no it's good let me tell you something
it takes any you can do anything you can
go from one spot it's so crazy it's kind
of like credit you know you get bad
credit one time all of a sudden you
think oh man this is where i have to
stay you know until you get your thing
together you get a job you work hard all
of a sudden you save your money and you
can have good credit again it's you can
change your body you can change your
life i'm a perfect example when i moved
out to california i was broke after the
nfl i had nothing and i look at where
i'm at right now and i just thank god
every day i go man here i am i'm in the
expendables i'm doing my own show are we
there yet i'm doing you know mike judge
and i are bringing president camacho
back he's doing all this stuff
[Applause]
and hey terry let's be honest the
highest of all highs you're here now
[Applause]
okay all right
oh wow this is all torn in here
i'm bleeding into my slacks
you made him pull a boob
i pulled a man boobie